yes this is it my hometown the place we as
members of this community call home and from
time to time leave for elsewhere
but this is home sweet home to us
they say every town has its Main Street well
this is ours we built it with civic pride and
remain proud of its dignity and friendly tolerable
character our fathers and mothers in our hometown
are just plain nice living folks the kind you
read about in storybooks you know Main Street
folks would say hello nice morning even when
it rains on Monday you see we really are the
folks the folks in other nations would like to
change places with these civic minded familiar
faces we all know in my hometown think our
town is something to shout about don't you
let's call on some of our business firms and
see what they're doing to help make our life
more pleasant let's see how they work to give us
the best the markets have to offer their purpose
is to please you to fulfill your desires and
needs to keep you well dressed and to keep
your homes properly furnished so that you may
maintain your place in society they are always
there to greet you with a pleasant smile and
to give you the best service possible you have
assurance of their dependability because they
are one of us in the permanence of our community
we can be justly proud of our shopping districts
and must realize that through their efforts and
foresight we have accumulated the necessary
shopping centers for the citizens of our town
we can rely on the fact that it is not necessary
to go beyond the limits of this community